this war has been devastating on
ukrainian's children not only in terms
of the number of children displaced
internally or rendered refugees but also
this terrible phenomenon of essentially
taking into custody children who have
Guardians and loved ones who want them
transitioning them to Russian occupied
territory or even deep into Russia
itself and potentially subjecting them
to foster care or even adoption we're
also hearing about children being
mistreated physically being subjected to
all kinds of political re-education
militarization training with weapons so
children have been a huge casualty of
this terrible war in Ukraine you will
know of course that child soldiers is
nothing new we knew about them in Rwanda
we knew we know about them being used in
Syria and Yemen this has a slight twist
to it doesn't it in that children be
taken from one country to another and
potentially indoctrinated to fight their
own people
that's right this is a very clear
violation of the 1949 Geneva conventions
which every country in the world has
ratified including Russia and you crane
members of the civilian population
cannot be taken and forced to fight on
the other side and that is a real
concern when you think about the
militarization of some of these young
children
obviously very impressionable especially
if they're taken at a very young age it
may be that they would have difficulty
even remembering their family members
when they're finally reunited with them
so this is a crisis as we know the
international criminal court has already
issued two arrest warrants for this very
crime a transfer of children from
Ukraine to Russia targeting not only
President Putin himself but his
children's quote unquote rights
commissioner Maria levovilova for
creating this system of abduction
forcible transfer and deportation and
then holding these children even though
they have loved ones who want them back
yeah I want to ask you about that I was
speaking earlier as well to a Ukrainian
war crimes loyal Gathering evidence and
helping with the investigation from from
on the ground I mean to what end it will
all of this be I mean to a certain
extent will we ever see President Putin
at the ICC being held accountable
obviously that's the the million dollar
question is as long as Putin stays
within Russia it will be very difficult
to get custody over him without some
sort of political transformation within
Russia but as it stands this arrest
warrant is highly significant it
expresses the international community's
condemnation of what is happening here
the ICC received an unprecedented
referral of over 40 States wanting the
court to take on an investigation of
what's happening in Russia and the
prosecutor of the ICC is working very
closely with war crimes investigators
and prosecutors within Ukraine in order
to divvy up and share information about
the various cases that might be brought
for war crimes crimes against humanity
and other atrocities
yeah and at the time Peter hofmansky
pointed out that they've issued the
arrest warrant for Maria levova belova
and President Putin but he said it was
up to the global Community to to take
them on in effect kind of saying look if
you've if Putin leaves Russia he is
potentially going to be arrested and
taken for justice to The Hague
that's right they're both now
essentially International
um fugitives from Justice and so any
state that is a member of the ICC is
under certain cooperation duties towards
the court so Putin should really think
twice before he travels anywhere not
only to potential territory of member
states of the court but also anywhere
that might have an extradition treaty
with a member of the court so he's
essentially trapped now in Russia we
know that he's quite Reckless with
Russian forces with Russian resources
Etc but he's not Reckless with his own
skin and so I think even if there's a 10
chance that he might be taken into
custody he really will be thinking twice
before he will travel anyway so he's
essentially trapped now within Russia
given the existence of this
International arrest warrant against him
How concerned are you
all the other war crimes we're seeing
unfold civilians being killed virtually
on a weekly basis now it's residential
buildings we saw shopping mall targeted
and of course we we've seen these
children being unlawfully deported How
concerned are you by what you're seeing
and hearing
it's staggering the the harm and then
the number of war crimes and other
atrocities we're seeing the prosecutor
General within Ukraine is cataloging
these and is now over 80 000 potentially
prosecutable crimes obviously it would
be impossible to prosecute all of these
but the Ukrainian prosecutor General is
working as you mentioned in the
introduction to this to this story
already charges have been brought cases
have been brought sentences have been
rendered some of these cases are done
with respect to prisoners of War
individuals who are in the custody of
Ukraine others are proceeding In
Absentia until they can achieve custody
over those individuals in addition the
courts within Europe are increasingly
United and coordinated a joint
investigative team has been created
amongst another a number of courts in
the region in order to be able to share
information and strategies around
bringing these charges when Russian
perpetrators begin to travel which we
know that they will eventually do as
they have done from other conflict zones
around the world they eventually will
travel they will need to leave or they
will want to leave and then they will be
within the sites of the world's war
crimes investigators
and I want to go back now to our special
report on the children being abducted
and in the young man that Dominic
waghorn our correspondents spoke to
extraordinary trauma being inflicted on
all ukrainians but and and the young
Russian soldiers as well who are being
led to their deaths but these young
children how how do we help them in the
future what what kind of trauma must
they have been through
indeed children are incredibly
vulnerable in these types of situations
they need care and Safety and Security
and the situation of armed conflict has
destroyed all of that they're seeing
their their homes destroyed their
schools destroyed friends disappeared
rendered displaced rendered refugees
this will be a generational problem all
of these investigations are being
conducted in a very careful
trauma-informed and survivor-centric way
the United States the European Union and
the United Kingdom have formed the
atrocity crimes Advisory Group that is
working very closely with the prosecutor
General in Ukraine to ensure that any
investigation involving harmed children
or otherwise traumatized individuals is
done according to International best
practices so as to not re-traumatize
these individuals but also so that they
can participate meaningfully in a
Justice process Justice can often be a
part of healing but it must be done
carefully because individuals being
interviewed multiple times Etc can often
re-traumatize them and so doing this
work carefully doing it well
interviewing individuals once but also
providing them with social services to
help them work through the experience
that they've happened in your earlier
story the mother spoke about how her son
couldn't speak about his experience it
was so awful for him and so finding a
safe space whereby he can explore the
the history his what he experienced and
come to terms with it and be able to to
work past it we do know that there is
something called post-traumatic growth
and that is what every single victim and
Survivor within Ukraine needs a
circumstance and a set of services and
assistance to enable them to get past
these terrible traumatic events in order
to experience post-traumatic growth and
to move on with their life projects and
what hope is there of some of these
children ever even being reunited with
their families if we're talking about 19
and a half thousand of a potential 300
000 being identified died
the United Nations has urged Russia to
create a system whereby we can trace
where these individuals have gone these
children have gone and and put in place
mechanisms to enable reunification and
the International Community in the
United Nations and the refugee High
Commissioners stand ready to assist with
that assuming they can get Russia's
consent and participation Russia is the
only entity that knows where these
children have gone where they may be now
and where they can be brought back home
it is terrible to think that parents
have to go and take the perilous journey
into Russia to try and identify their
children and to bring them back
themselves back through a war zone so
Russia needs to participate with the
International Community in order to
reveal the identities of all of the
children that they have taken where they
are currently and what plans they have
in order to reunite them to their
families
Ambassador Beth Van skirk thanks very
much indeed for joining us good to have
you with us on your Insight